hello I'm in the style chakra guy
remember it so you don't have to say
have you ever wanted to see Cary Elwes
Gary Oldman circle Gabriel Byrne Pierce
Brosnan Balki from perfect strangers
Jane Seymour that chick from heroes Don
Rickles and Eric Idle in a movie
together no nobody wants to see that
what they did in the fucking piece of
shit called quest for Camelot back in
the mid-90s when Animation Studios for
trying to take down Disney by doing
exactly what they did
Warner Brothers gave us quest for
Camelot this cheap uninvented knockoff
of the Disney style is so blind and so
impassionate that you'd swear the steal
they're fighting with will be much
better characters and actually some of
them do but I'm getting ahead of myself
let's take a look at this medieval blast
from the assets ey shows David the Dark
Ages so we start off in Pride schlock as
we see our main hero who's a girl named
Kaylee she's the daughter of one of the
knights of the round table played by
Gabriel Byrne what's the Knights name
well it doesn't really matter they're
having fun in this opening which
obviously means he's a goner I'm coming
with you daddy
yes when you're old enough Kaylee's one
day I would be a knight like fuck well
you better work on growing that penis
honey it's the Dark Ages it sucks for
everybody so the father joins the other
Knights as they venture towards their
destination they ride to Camelot when I
pull out they breed
no no this is meant to be taken
seriously the real deal
there are they see me nights in this
version so much will now divide equal
shares of countries time all right but
any of those nights are richer here is a
good fuck out of here
Oh Bobby
now I don't want to give anything away
here but one of these guys is going to
be the villain
can you guess who Wow your your dumbest
actually it's this guy and his name is
Rupert and what you know it he's played
by Gary Coleman who played another
obvious bad guy that everybody trusted
as dr. Smith in lost in space which
oddly enough came out the exact same
year this movie did come on Gary ol and
you're a great actor why are you
choosing these obvious villain roles at
the time I mean there's just nothing
subtle about did somebody question by
subtle acting
oh come on dr. Smith you're a so loss a
fucking train wreck on a boat oh come
now without several differences between
me and that Roopa fellow for example I
want the Seas power when control through
a legion of spiders but that ruber guy
want to see power and control - but not
with spiders God said you know you need
to do dr. Smith does it involve spiders
no you need to be diabolical actually
fool people to think of your kind gentle
caring person you think you can do that
think the boat sort of sailed up that
one all right well don't bother me
anymore I got a review to do wait
there's one more important thing it's
imperative that you must know why what
spiders you doomed so rumor goes mad
with power and tries to take Arthur's
sword and throw the other knights
talking but Kiwis father is killed in
the process
big flippin surprise they bury him at
his home as Cayley tries to adjust to
not having a father anymore
when you squeeze that horse's mane you
get a song fine cut ten years later as
Kaley has grown up into hi Belle from
Beauty and the Beast fancy your image
being shamefully ripped off here I mean
my god revived even trying it's Belle
it's fucking Belle look just change the
outfits around a bit here and yeah it's
Belle
it's fucking bow okay okay maybe I'm
being too critical I mean maybe she just
lost like her it's not like they pulled
run through the field with their arms
open the animals on a farm or singing a
song about wanting more out of life and
being stuck in an environment that
doesn't welcome her free spirit oh wait
yes I fucking dough so while she still
dreams about being a knight King Arthur
and his round table talk about how
nothing horrible is going wrong just
before something horrible a Griffin
comes and steals Excalibur but suddenly
loses it in a valley of thorns
uh what are those things
are those monsters are those magic beans
what explain homie what nothing no okay
just ignore the giant elephant in the
room a while longer
so the Knights send out the word about
Excalibur's theft bang Excalibur it's
been stolen I said no I speak horn so
kami wants to be a great Knight by
finding a scallop er and returning it to
Camelot that's a job for the night not
for younger I don't want to be a knight
I'll go on grand adventures fighting
evil rescuing damsels in distress hello
how character trait
what is it Ansel anyway goodbye I
character trait I want to save Camelot
but before she can become the world's
greatest knight rumor takes over their
village how by doing the most diabolical
thing he can possibly fathom singing I
have a plan we have a look now watch me
create my mechanical army cry okay is he
just making up this song as he goes
seriously I can't even catch the melody
a mom whose lines in anyway hold down
some more rehearse than this and those
were improvised with this motion of
flames acne what the chicken green smoke
zapping and now he's an axe what what
what what what hi remember me I'm the
audience you want film Anna what the
fuck's going on okay from what I can
gather I guess rubra has a magic juice
that can combine living things with
inanimate objects so he uses it to
melted followers and a half man/half
weaponry Bonnie what's the story behind
him I heard something about some witches
he fought in from what witches are
working in the Acme corporation yeah the
corporation supports the Black Arts how
does this work you want a lab resident
it's plenty movie explaining anyway well
that's going on Kaylee escapes in
probably the most improbable way
possible the guard just let her go
really you can come up with the berries
in the net come to strengthen all these
guards now we gotcha
I never go like you're going I have pass
so the Griffon returns as it turns out
he's been working for uber all this time
but unfortunately he informs him that he
lost Excalibur what is the one thing
that can keep me from my conquest of
Camelot now that the girl I took
screaming lessons from the villain in
warriors of virtue I pray
oh wait a minute I know this song this
is the prayer that song has been sung by
like everybody Celine Dion Josh Groban
Charlotte Church this is a really famous
song this is where it came from
gotta be shitting me no why could this
story inspire I saw that popular they
had to over it that before they even
knew about the movies but they may be a
wrong maybe the scene and that song go
perfectly together maybe you can't
imagine one without the other they just
met up perfectly I don't know let's take
a look
Oh
unbelievable not even close
I have never seen a song so poorly
matched up you got monsters with weapons
for hands I got a woman fleeing in fear
a chasing into a creepy forest and a
chicken who's a fucking axe are those
really the images that come to your mind
when you hear this song if so then you
are fucked I mean this song simply
doesn't go in an action scene how would
you like it up in Sin City they started
playing this song over the really
intense moments
so she enters the Forbidden Forest where
the henchmen are not far behind
I'm still going to be the world's
greatest night that's why I'm running
away from danger that's closing it
behind me but I'm doing it very bravely
but she's saved by a hermit named
Garrett played by Cary Elwes a blind man
who quite frankly makes Daredevils moves
look like a five-year-old gymnast
so Kelly tells Garrett about the stolen
sword as they rush to retrieve it
right we're going after it all right not
you me and Aiden we work alone yes in
medieval times even a blind man has more
credibility to go into danger than a
woman does it pays to have balls
well I think no reason why I can't come
along I mean ah whose voice is that
Cary Elwes suddenly transform the quake
like a bridge
oh wait how can the plants move look
look leads are flying please Liz this is
Camelot not fucking firm volley how the
fuck are they able to do this
I'm sorry this just really irritates me
why do the plants fucking move you're
not riding lord of the rings' you can't
just make up your own theology this one
already exists if you're gonna have
plants move you have to have a reason
for it explain to me explain
I just need your help this once
oh right all right but you just saw the
friggin song about why she can't come
with you and then all the sudden she can
I really want to come with you
yeah like a bridge Spanky's boy but the
comedic ax chicken god I can't believe I
just put those words together
tell Hoover about Kiwis escape you rip
hope well the plot makes no sense we
have no originality and the songs are
gonna be more successful than the actual
movie you wretched mythological moron a
Cabrio oh by the way did I mention that
the chicken is played by Julia White
doesn't that make him just so much more
likeable but if someone tries to touch
you in a place or in a way that make you
feel uncomfortable then no good so just
when you think the big urban Owens can't
possibly be Phil anymore guess what else
they toss our way a double dragon god I
wish no this is a funny two-headed
dragon voiced by Eric Idle and Don
wrinkles together at last
Camelot the restrooms the theater
waitresses the actresses are they funny
no but they do love to sing on the
notches songs then just pop the hell out
of nowhere
I think Dino twinken with my note I'd be
dragon nice hey hey this is like that
thing rather lame stood in Aladdin but
the comedic references to modern-day
elements that won't exist for hundreds
of years except when he did it was
mildly annoying and when you do it it's
torturously annoying
yeah where does Elvis fit into the
Arthur budget exactly huh
you never saw anything come on Garrett
get on Nate him ha date so what we're
just gonna move forward like nothing
happened
those two dragons just like a
three-minute song and you're not even
going to acknowledge it these songs have
no purpose
they're like drive-by musicals if you
want good singing fine but make sure
they have a point where are you know
fucking entertaining how about holding
your breath so rhubarb oh I'm sorry
goober catches up with our heroes and a
test but they all escape as Kayla gets
Garrett somewhere safe to mend his
wounds I'm sorry
get this guy oh shut up does everybody
have to sing in this movie look at him
it actually looks like it's hurting as
he sings why would you sing if you're in
pain are you afraid of talent scouts
gonna drop by on your deathbed I hear
heartbeat just go
oh wait wait no no you can't get away
with that movie you need some
explanation how can elite evaporate into
his skin and just magically cure it no
no that does not have a movie that just
does unless you oh I don't know so after
the hue and touch of leaves they make it
to the cave where Excalibur is and it
turns out is being held by all rockbiter
a rockbiter for God's sakes you're not
even trying
first your eyeball fell and now you got
rid of the rockbiter from neverending
story this is just painful right better
what were you thinking
it looked like a good strong script get
a net the bad guys enter as well but
luckily our heroes get Excalibur before
they can touch it
the ogres did he just say the ogre is
but the ogres okay that's not a sentence
that's a now that's not even a good now
in fact this is where Gary Oldman should
have known this movie was going to suck
when he had to just say the line the
ogres bought gentlemen I want to talk to
you about this line which is that the
locust but what about it is is that it
simply the oak is buckets and ogres but
what's wrong with an ogres butt oh
nothing I have nothing against the ogres
but I'm sure the ogres butt is lovely
however there doesn't seem to be any
reason for the ogres but how about
perhaps a verb or predicate clause like
look out for the ogres butt or oh no we
are under the ogres butt or if you'll
permit me woe is me and all others who
are trapped under ochres but this isn't
Congress butters and plural duly noted
but at least that one came with a
conjunction grammatically speaking I
think that makes the ogres but much more
palatable look just stick to the script
but I ask you how does it make any sense
I'm a Shakespearean trained at a witch
of that spider and lost in space focus
but it is get the work puppet so our
heroes get out and finally make it home
each only a model Shh oh but just as
they're about to hand in the sword
together you deliver it I I don't belong
in that walk what do you mean you don't
belong you're incredible you see better
than how both people can see in fact or
even the glide come on
like every tree no this makes no sense
you don't belong in a world with cozy
houses comfy beds and guaranteed
security but you do belong in a world of
killer plants giant monsters and Dragons
that can fucking eat you hello you're
not hard-of-hearing just listen to a
good opportunity and take advantage of
it
you moron well of course the bad guys
catch up with Kili and steal the sword
away from her
uber takes the potion out of his
cleavage and forges Excalibur onto his
arm the scaly is kidnapped and uses
leverage for her mother to get the
villains into Camelot oh and in answer
to your question earlier honey about
what a damsel in distress is it's a
stupid female who knows how to take care
of herself but yet constantly has to be
rescued
in other words yo its lady Juliana lower
the bridge and what also let in the dark
shadowy figure with the black hood black
horse and black saddle I'm sure he can
be totally trusted and still the world's
greatest knight blimpy at Georgia wait a
minute she can turn into a bug guy there
was no transformation scene even talk to
anyone that wasn't even a line of
dialogue aren't you gonna fill us in
movie aren't you gonna let us know
what's going on
oh sorry
so Kaley is gauged Ruper attacks and
Garrett changes his mind and come back
to help do I feel lucky well do ya huh
sorry I'm doing four - that's it a wrap
it up the quarter goober at the stone
that Excalibur would pull out up and
trick him into slipping it back in this
causes a magical bullshit that blows
them up and get this magically heals
everybody why how I prefer you to my
first nuclear explosion that's right
everyone is totally and permanently
healed except for the blind guy hey you
bastards what was saving everything that
could possibly be saved in this movie
just not enough for you
Excalibur's a boom hole so Kaylee and
Garrett are finally made Knights all the
people rejoice and celebrate by
inventing Riverdance
well JD I did absolutely nothing I was a
complete waste of animation
on second thought let's not go to
Camelot it is a silly place right yeah I
think I threw something up their quest
for Camelot of evil times restaurant is
more dignity than this piece of shit
the characters are ripoff the story has
no connection to the Arthur legend and
oh yeah there's a bajillion thing that
are never explained in fact I want an
answer I want an answer right now and
not only do I want that answer I want
answer that's the most innocent perfect
being that I can think of Mary Poppins
that's right
Mary Poppins is going to be my
representation of this movie so tell me
Marian - Tommy explained this bullshit
that we just witnessed first of all I
would like to make one thing quite clear
huh I never explain anything
fuck younger oh my god oh my god I just
killed Mary Poppins I just killed my
first childhood I got the movie it's
done to me baby bump it I'm so sorry
Mary Poppins Guildford - okay I got a
couple points for killing a more
innocent Disney characters unless you
stop - Critic I remember it so you don't
have to oh holy mystery nostalgia crazy
oh I'm sorry quest for Camelot maybe do
it hi I understand
the August